let's turn to the other big story that
we're following this morning the Iowa
caucuses as you know Tony's at the Drake
diner in Des Moines where candidates
stop in to mingle with the voters and
Tony I have to say that is a very
good-looking diner it is a very
good-looking diner a lot of neon and a
lot of people here even though it's
early how can I put the mistakes here
today in Iowa voters may not pick a
president tonight but the chances are
very good that they're going to
eliminate some contenders they're gonna
be casting the first in the nation
caucus picks for president tonight 7:00
p.m.
it follows 2200 campaign events over
more than two years of town halls and
county fairs and steak fries and corn
feeds and visits of diners like this one
yesterday the candidates were all over
the state making a final pitch to voters
and it is a close one the CBS News
battleground tracker poll shows a very
tight race for the first choice former
Vice President Joe Biden and senator
Bernie Sanders are tied with 25 percent
support each but former South Bend
Indiana mayor Pete Budaj and senator
Elizabeth Warren are also in a position
to win some delegates if their ground
game comes out and works for him senator
Amy Klobuchar rounds out the top five in
our poll we were on the trail yesterday
all day trying to catch up with as many
of these leading candidates as we could
as they made that final plea to voters
that get out in caucus the middle class
does well everybody does well as
Democrats vying for the White House
crisscross to Iowa so did we women win
let's get this gun first stop and
overflowing rally for senator Elizabeth
Warren we spoke with her backstage about
how the economic pie is distributed we
got some free pie here free pie an issue
we covered last week with a real pie how
many pieces of the pie would you put on
the middle class
you had it exactly right you showed how
it is that the wealthy have so much pie
when I do a wealth tax it's not to hand
out money it's to make the investments
how do you like your chances on oh I
like him but shortly after Warren took
the stage we've got a short drive to
make it to the Buddha judge event on
time
let's go thirty-eight-year-old mayor
Pete Budaj edge is the youngest Democrat
in the field how do you define victory
tomorrow our place only I'll leave it to
the pun is to set up the goalposts but
what I know is leaving the possibility
that victory could be something other
than first place we definitely need to
have a strong showing here because this
is our chance to show and not just tell
our ability to get folks out to the
polls in about the organization that is
eventually going to go on and defeat
Donald Trump I do have a nickname where
I want to give him former president
former president Donald Trump meanwhile
attacks on president Trump echoed across
the Hawkeye steam in America the
president is not King the law is king we
gotta go we're gonna go try to see
Bernie Sanders he ended up at a Des
Moines bar on Super Bowl Sunday filled
with Bernie Sanders supporters the
Vermont senator predicted victory then
sped off before we could catch him we
tried we did our very best polls open
tonight here at 7:00 p.m. Central Time
but it could be a very long night with
some new rules that could see second
tier candidates pushing leading
contenders to victory
you